okay all right welcome back everybody so
today we're going to talk a little bit
more about potential flow and we're
actually going to start coding some
things up in MATLAB which will be kind
of a nice change of pace to actually see
some real like physical systems in
action before doing that just a few kind
of administrative items so the final
exam is going to come out today after my
office hours so I'll post it right
around 11:30 and it'll be due at about
5:00 p.m. on Friday okay so to turn it
in you can either hand it in to me
personally you can slip it under my door
or you can put it in the catalyst drop
box and if you do slip it under my door
please just send me and my T as a quick
email so that I know like I have a
record that you actually did submit it
okay
the exam will be four hours just like
last time I would strongly recommend
trying to take it in less time like if
this is prepare preparing you for
qualifying exams I would try to take it
in under two hours and then you can go
back and check your answers and make
sure that the U you have everything I
took the exam last night and it wasn't
as hard as I thought so that's good but
I did write the exam so it's not super
difficult but it is completely
cumulative so there's stuff on OTE their
stuff on numerical analysis and calculus
vector calculus pretty much everything
we covered you know so you'll need to
know about your Taylor series and your
finite difference derivatives and you
know order Delta x squared error and
things like that any questions about the
exam yeah double check arranges with
mess
that's fine with me yeah open notes like
last time you can use your homework
solutions I prefer you did not use the
solutions that I posted online from
other people but all of the homework
solutions are now posted so homeworks
one through five there are solutions on
the website so before you take the exam
you can you know if there's something
you weren't sure about you can figure it
out from there
yeah you can use the class notes the
videos my PDF notes your handwritten
notes whatever that's fine just no
internet no books no other people know
other people's homework solutions okay
other questions at the exam
so I have to admit that writing exams is
not my favorite thing and it's not the
thing I'm best at I wrote a note when I
was writing this last night that I
should learn how to write better exams
and so I've decided to solicit an extra
credit problem from all of you so I
haven't decided on the exact amount of
extra credit but usually what extra
credit means to me is that if you're
kind of on the border between a point
grade like a 3 6 and a 3 7 or 3 7 & a 3
8 or 2 8 and a 2 9 or whatever then
extra credit would kind of be the push
you need to bump you to that next level
so the extra credit this is not on the
exam this is completely separate would
essentially be to come up with your own
final exam question this could be on
anything from the class Oh des linear
algebra numerical calculus vector
calculus this can be something that you
have seen in other classes like when you
were undergrads pick your favorite class
the best you know homework or exam
problem you ever had that's fine as long
as you you know write it out and solve
it what I would really prefer our
problems that have some physical
motivation okay so a neat one that I had
when I was in vector calculus was this
problem with ants walking on a doughnut
so the problem this is a little too
open-ended for an exam but this is kind
of the idea is let's say that an ant is
at Point a and the ant wants to get to
point B what is the shortest distance
path on the doughnut from path a to path
T point A to point B okay so this is a
hard vector calculus problem but it's
easy to explain it has a physical
context like everyone understands the
statement of the problem even if you
don't know how to solve it okay so a
good problem might be something like
that or you know but I just want to get
ideas from you so you guys are going to
write my final exams for the next five
years hopefully
okay okay so anytime I think before like
next Friday would be fine I'm going to
assign grades next Friday okay moving on
other things the exam is posted I have
office hours today extra credit problem
I think that's basically it are there
any questions for me I don't have a ton
prepared today so up there are any
questions about anything we do have some
time
No okay
all right good so we're going to talk a
bit more about potential flow and I'm
going to go a little deeper into the
math and then I'm going to go a lot more
applied and we're actually going to
hopefully the next two lectures are
going to be a little bit satisfying in
the sense that we're going to start with
a PDE and this is Laplace's equation
okay we're going to start with some PDE
and from this PDE we're going to get a
vector field so one is we write down a
PDE that has some properties we like
right we want a flow that has no
rotation and is incompressible for
example and then what we're going to do
is get a vector field V and this is
going to be a vector field in the plane
of two spatial variables x and y and
then three we're going to use V as the
right-hand side for a particles OD e for
a particle trajectory so we're going to
say something like X dot y dot is going
to equal you know V 1 of X Y V 2 of X Y
and we're actually going to integrate
particles through this vector field
which was a solution to a PDE okay and
this is going to kind of round out all
of the ideas in the class that we've
we've had so far so far and really
solidify why we care about vector fields
why Laplace equation and potential flow
are interesting and how you can actually
use them ok ok so I'm pretty sure I've
asked everybody this about five times
but just one more time remind me how
many of you have had some complex
function theory like some okay so this
is like about 15% of the class okay so
the first week of next quarter I'm
probably going to try to teach you as
much complex analysis as I possibly can
in one week okay oftentimes people spend
three weeks or four weeks on complex
analysis in the second analysis class
and I think that's crazy but there is a
ton of useful stuff that I want you to
know in complex analysis and so I'm
going to teach you like the first week
of next quarter is going to be pretty
intense I'm going to go like basically
all of complex function theory that I
can pack into three lectures and we're
going to start a little bit now so we
have two deep attention flow and
remember that our 2d potential flow had
a couple of conditions so we had this
vector field V was given by the gradient
of a potential fee and fee had some
properties so well okay the divergence
of V I wanted it to equal zero and I
also wanted the curl of e to equal zero
and that's true if and only if
the laplacian of fee is equal to zero
okay so we derive this in the last
lecture that if I want to have this nice
vector field V that's incompressible and
irrotational then it has to be the
gradient of some special function fee
that solves Laplace's equation okay we
know this from from last time now it
turns out that there's another really
really special function so fee is a
special function fee is a very special
function not all functions are as
special as fee called the potential
function and in problems like
gravitation or electrostatics it
literally means the potential right the
gravitational potential or the
electrostatic potential so this is not
some like trick name this is essentially
like has the same meaning as in physics
but there's another special function and
the special function is closely related
and we'll talk about this next quarter
so another special function psy is
called the stream function and it's
going to be useful because it
essentially is going to tell me what
stream lines are in my vector field so
if I followed a particle it'll tell me
where that particle goes some kind of
like what the curve of particle
trajectories are using this stream
function and so what I can do in lots of
problems I can write down a complex
valued potential in terms of a complex
variable Z so Z is X plus iy okay Z is
just a complex number complex variable
and this is going to equal V of X and y
plus i sy of x and y
okay I'm just writing down notation
right now I'm just telling you what the
names of things are and then we're going
to tell you how to use these okay so we
know that there's this special function
fee if you use a function of x and y and
it's real value is just a real valued
scalar function and I'm telling you that
there is another special function called
SCI it's also real valued and it's a
function of x and y and psy also
satisfies Laplace's equation okay and so
for lots of systems where you can write
down this potential Phi there is also
this stream function sigh okay and often
it's going to be easier to get the
vector field from the stream function
than from the potential I'm going to
kind of show you what this means in an
example so what we're going to be
looking at here are complex functions of
a complex variable and we're going to
split that function up into its real
part and its imaginary part and each of
those are their own spatial scalar
functions and these potentials and
stream functions are going to be really
really useful for telling us what the
vector field looks like for physical
systems okay so let's let's probably
start with an example and remember our
vector field V equals V 1 V 2 and it
equals partial V partial X partial V
partial Y which is just the gradient of
fee remember our vector field is equal
to the gradient of our potential which
means it's just you know the first X
component is partial V partial X and the
y component is partial V partial Y and
it turns out that if you can write down
this special complex potential function
then this is also equal to
- partial sigh partial Y and partial by
partial X so this is really really
really really special if I have this
complex valued potential function that
can be broken up into a scalar real
valued potential plus an I times a
scalar real valued stream function and
both of these functions satisfy
Laplace's equation then this is also
true that I can get my velocity field
view on v2 either from my potential or
from my stream function
okay just by taking partial derivatives
okay so a lot of really really common
okay so for example if I wanted to know
what fluid flow did past a cylinder
right if I wanted to know like what the
streamlines were of some very slow flow
path to cylinder a solid cylinder I
could pick some special potential
function that satisfied these boundary
conditions that the flow had to be 0 on
the boundary and I could then find the
velocity field everywhere and I can also
do that for airfoils to find out what
the streamlines are past an airfoil okay
so this is I'm probably going to do this
as a homework problem in the first week
of next quarter is actually have you
derived the velocity field for these two
problems from the potential function but
for right now I'm going to start with a
simpler set of examples okay so
oftentimes what we're going to do is
we're going to take some complex valued
variable Z and we're going to say this
complex potential Z is equal to Z to the
N
okay now Z to the N is not that
complicated for a complex variable you
just literally like if I wanted Z
squared I would literally take X plus iy
times X plus iy and I would get x
squared plus 2i times XY plus I squared
Y squared which is just minus y squared
and then I collect all of the real parts
on one side and all of the imaginary
parts on the other and I'd say that this
is x squared plus y so our x squared
minus y squared plus 2i XY okay so in
this case x squared minus y squared
would be my potential fee and 2xy would
be my stream function sigh okay
and you can verify that this actually
satisfies Laplace's equation so these
functions really do satisfy Laplace's
equation so fee of XY equals x squared
minus y squared sigh of XY equals to X Y
so let's just do a few things so I'm
telling you that this is a particularly
useful potential and if I change the
power n I can get lots of different cool
vector fields I'm going to show you a
number of them so this is kind of a
great building block this is a building
block potential and now what I've done
is I've picked a power of two so my
potential function is Z squared and
we're going to work out this example for
what the vector field what the potential
flow looks like for this potential when
I take Z squared okay
so first let's verify let's do a few
things
so let's verify that Phi and sy are both
satisfy Laplace's equation okay so first
thing we're going to verify is that Phi
and sy satisfy Laplace's equation okay
okay so how do I do that what's what are
the steps I need to do to satisfy to see
if that if Laplace's equation is
satisfied right so I would basically
take I could take the gradient of Phi
and then take the divergence of it or I
could just compute the second partial
derivative with respect to X and add it
to the second partial derivative with
respect to Y so let's just do that let's
say partial squared Phi partial x
squared plus partial squared Phi partial
y squared equals what's okay what's the
second partial derivative with respect
to X two
okay and the second partial derivative
with respect to y -2 okay so this is
equal to two minus two equals zero
okay good applause is equation half the
holds so in principle the velocity field
I get from this should be both
irrotational and and compressible right
okay
let's also verify that size satisfies
Laplace's equation so partial squared
sigh partial x squared plus partial sy
squared partial y squared well the
second partial derivative with respect
to X is zero and the second partial
derivative with respect to Y is also
zero for sighs so this one's even easier
that's zero so this is great we verified
that both of our potential function and
stream function satisfy Laplace's
equation okay so now let's compute the
induced velocity field let's compute V
using the potential function okay so two
we're going to compute V okay so V
equals v1 v2 and it's given by the
partial of V with respect to X which is
2x alright and the partial of V with
respect to Y which is minus 2y okay good
seems reasonable let's also verify it by
taking these partial derivatives with
respect to the stream function okay feel
like I messed something up here
is there a negative I'm missing
somewhere here let's say this should be
down here okay good well then that's
obviously satisfied thank you right so
if I take the partial of my side with
respect to X I get to with respect to Y
I get to X and if I take minus partial
side with respect to X I get minus 2y
which is my velocity potential so I
could get this either way from fee or
from sigh okay good so soon we're
actually going to plot what this vector
field looks like but let's just for
sanity's sake because we haven't done
this a single time yet let's actually
verify that this vector field is
incompressible and irrotational okay
because I told you it's going to be
let's actually convince ourselves that
this is true
so three is going to be V is
incompressible and irrotational okay
so let's do incompressible first so
divergence of V equals what's well it's
the dot product of partial partial X and
partial partial Y with 2x and minus 2y
so that equals 2 minus 2 is 0 so we are
definitely incompressible okay and for
irrotationality let's say curl of V
equals the determinant of partial
partial X partial partial Y partial
partial Z and we have 2x minus 2y and 0
so the determinant of this is in the I
direction we have partial of 0 and
there's no Z here so the partial with
respect to Z is 0 so 0 I
in the J direction we have partial of
zero is zero minus partial of 2x with
respect to Z is also zero and the K
Direction is where it gets a little
interesting but that's not actually that
interesting because partial of Y with
respect to X is zero and partial of X
with respect to Y is also zero good so
we have irrotationality also okay so
what we're doing here is we're taking
this fancy complex valued potential
function I broken it up into its real
valued function part and it's complex
valued function part I'm calling that
the potential function and the stream
function and from the potential function
and the stream function since they both
satisfy Laplace's equation I get a
vector field that's both irrotational
and incompressible okay so not all
vector fields V can be written as the
gradient of a potential but special ones
that can be written as a gradient of a
laplacian potential satisfy these
properties ok so now let's actually draw
this thing any questions before we go
deeper in the rabbit hole no questions
okay maybe you think about your
questions okay so now let's actually
plot this vector field right so we had
this potential and now we have a vector
field V equals V 1 V 2 equals 2x minus
2y okay so
okay what is the meaning of v1 and v2
like what is this vector field
physically mean okay so I have a
velocity in the x-direction and a
velocity in the Y direction and these
velocities are not just defined at one
point but they're defined at all spatial
points x and y okay so let's take an XY
plane and let's start drawing these
vectors at a bunch of points x and y ok
so at the point zero zero what's my
velocity field look like zero there's
nothing happening here that's a fixed
point okay what about at x equals 1 y
equals zero so I have a positive
velocity only in the X direction okay so
here I have a positive velocity in the X
direction
what about at a point way down in the X
direction same well it's actually moving
faster now right so that's actually a
bigger vector moving outward but only in
the X direction similarly in Y let's say
I start with 1 what is this vector look
like in the zero one position so just a
negative Y velocity right because I have
zero X's and I have a positive one Y so
I get negative two in this direction so
I get a negative vector here similarly
if I went down and why I would be
pointing up and if I went left in X I
would be pointing left and so on and so
forth what if I take a point like x
equals 1 y equals 1 that's a weird one
so I'm going so x equals 1 y equals 1
then I would have 2 minus 2 so I'm going
to the right two and down two so here I
have kind of that kind of vector here I
think I have a left vector here I
probably have a vector that looks like
that okay and you can keep going right I
just have these kinds of vectors so I'm
moving down on the y axis and so in the
y axis I'm moving towards the light
towards the x axis if I'm on the x axis
I'm moving away from the y axis and if
I'm anywhere else I'm kind of moving
from the y axis down to the x axis okay
so does this starting to look familiar
ok what does this look like this is a
saddle point ok so if I said X dot
equals v1 of X comma Y and y dot equals
v2 of X comma Y or set another way
yeah that's that's fine then this is
just the same as X dot y dot equals to
zero zero minus 2xy ok so what we have
here is that if I so this is a vector
field given by some potential function
ok we wrote the potential function down
over there and if I in this vector field
the potential it comes from fee is the
solution to a PDE Laplace's equation so
if I look at where a particle goes in
this vector field I get an OD e out ok
so this is an OD e induced by my
velocity field
so I've been saying this a lot the same
thing is true if I have the fluid flow
in the Gulf of Mexico right there's some
partial differential equation that tells
me what the velocity is going to have to
look like at every point right there's
some conservation of mass momentum and
energy that give me PD es the solution
of those PD es gives me some vector
field V but then at the end of the day
what I use that vector field for is
maybe I drop some blob of oil and I see
where that blob of oil goes and I see
that here you know eventually it gets
stretched and kind of compressed in the
y-direction probably should draw this a
little better it gets compressed in the
y-direction and stretched in the
x-direction but because this is a
potential flow this is incompressible
and irrotational so the total volume of
this blob of oil is going to be the same
as the total volume of this blob of oil
right because it gets stretched in one
direction it gets compressed in the
other so that's what incompressibility
means and it's also not rotating it's
just getting sheared or stretched okay
so it's kind of cool super simple
example a nice you know potential
function which is a complex number
squared and you get a saddle vector
field and you can really start thinking
about what in compressibility and
irrotationality means in this context
okay questions about this
I'll wait for a little bit any questions
okay so maybe this is clear this is
something we're going to revisit a lot
more so I wouldn't be too worried if
this seems a little abstract so there's
a couple of things if I was going to say
where this confuses me I just made up
this potential like where did this
potential come from how did I know that
this was a solution of a process
equation I didn't tell you that at all
right I just made this function up I
told you that this special function is
going to give you potential functions
and stream functions that definitely
solve Laplace's equation but I
definitely did not tell you how that's
true and that's advanced and that's
something we'll talk about later but
that's something that you should be
thinking about so that would be a good
question is why does this complex
potential guarantee that I'm going to
have nice stream functions and potential
functions that satisfy the Laplace
namely why does this function give me
irrotational and incompressible vector
fields out okay it's a weird question
it's like I'm not sure I know the answer
right now I'm gonna have to figure that
out over the break sorry I know it's
true for lots of N it's true for N
equals two thirds and three halves N
equals negative 1 and 0 n equals 1 and 2
I haven't verified it for all n but I
would suspect the answer is definitely
yes for positive and that are integers
okay yeah so okay I do know the answer
this so if N is a positive integer then
this will definitely give you nice
functions out and the reason I know that
is because for positive n these will be
continuously differentiable and you can
take all higher derivatives you could
take the fifth the sixth the seventh the
ninth the billionth derivative of these
and they would be smooth and continuous
in fact they would probably zero a lot
of them right and so that means that
this is an analytic function for
positive integer ends ok that's analytic
means something very special and complex
number theory it means that these
functions will satisfy Laplace's
equation that's basically what it means
and that means that I can write down
this and this as equal this is called
the Co shiri mod conditions okay so this
is something we'll talk about in the
first week of next next quarter for Z
equals negative for N equals negative
numbers like 1 over Z 1 over Z squared 1
over Z cubed you get funky kinds of
singularities at the origin so
everywhere else outside of the origin
your flow is going to be nice and
incompressible and irrotational but at
the origin you're going to have weird
stuff happening so you could have flows
that actually do have a net circulation
a net you know integrated vorticity
because of what's happening at the
singularity ok that's called the Cauchy
Riemann integral theorem and we're going
to talk about that also probably not in
the first week
sorry it's called the the residue
theorem for those of you who have done
complex analysis and then for weird
fractional powers of n all bets are off
okay so we're going to find that if I
take the square root of a complex number
then I actually have to you know I have
two unique sets of solutions and so you
can get weird multi valued functions
when this is like 2/3 or 1/3 or 1/9 or
things like that but for positive powers
of n for positive integer n you can
verify that these will always satisfy
Laplace's equation and that would
probably be a really really good idea to
prepare for like the first week of next
quarter okay yeah great question let's
see so there's a few things I want to
tell you that get back to Stokes's
theorem and Gauss's theorem because
these are really really useful and what
we're going to do is I mean essentially
I'm just going to restate what it means
to have zero divergence and zero curl
okay so if I have my vector field and
it's doing some some thing can't really
draw this that well
but I have some vector field that's
doing its thing okay and let's say that
I take a big close contour integral like
this a right-handed not right-handed
that's left-handed while I'm left-handed
so let's say I take a big contour
integral C and I integrate various
quantities I either calculate what is
the flux through this contour C or I say
what is the integrated tangent component
of velocity around the circle and we're
going to find that those quantities are
really really important and are equal to
zero for conservative potential flows
okay
so the integral around C of my velocity
field dotted with and I'm going to
define some things I'm going to define a
tangent vector U and I'm going to define
a normal vector n okay tangent to the
curve and normal to the curve so if I
look at the component of my velocity
field that is tangent to the curve and I
integrate that across the whole surface
the whole the whole the whole boundary
of the surface
so what theorem do I use to simplify
this
I'm basically looking at how much of my
vector field points in the tangent
direction and I'm adding up all of those
components around this closed circle
okay how many of you think it's Gauss's
theorem how many think it's greens
theorem how many think it's Stokes is
greens theorem okay I'm not getting
enough hands there's no conservation of
hand those are the only theorems I
taught you so this is a Stokes theorem
problem okay so what that tells me is
that this is equal to the surface sorry
the area integral inside C of the curl
of V times some larger you know this
kind of little surface patch is da if
you like but what do we know about the
curl of this vector field zero
everywhere okay it's zero everywhere so
this equals zero everywhere that's kind
of cool that tells me that if I take and
integrate the tangent component of this
over any closed contour see whether it's
teeny or huge or the right half plane or
the left half plane it's always going to
equal zero that's a pretty powerful
statement and we know this because our
potential function satisfies Laplace's
equation actually really just because
our vector field B is the gradient of a
potential that's all we need
okay another one let's say so this is
called the circulation and it makes
sense because it would tell you how much
this flow is circulating if I had a bit
big vortex here and I integrated around
that contour then I would actually get a
positive number or a negative number so
circulation is really really important
for aircraft if you get on an airplane
and the airplane wings don't have
circulation get off the airplane okay
flux so let's say that we want to
compute the flux of this vector field
out of this contour C or through this
contour C so what I want to know is is
this vector field is this flow
Oh is it carrying fluid is there a net
inflow of fluid or a net outflow of
fluid or is there a net balance of fluid
or of Nasr of whatever we're advective
in this this vector field
it's called ad vecten because you're
moving it through a vector field
convecting vectors vector so the flux is
the integral around C of my vector field
dotted in the normal Direction D PS
right I'm going to integrate this around
around C so this is the amount of stuff
that is coming out of C and how do we
solve this integral okay Gauss's
divergence theorem so what does Gauss's
divergence tell me that this has to be
so a volume or so you know a
one-dimensional higher integral over
inside of C of what divergence of V D a
and that also equals zero because we
have this special potential flow so this
tells me that no matter where I start
with a blob I don't have a net inflow or
outflow of material into that blob and
it's also kind of cool that if I take
this blob and I flow it its volume is
going to stay the same
that's also what it means so this one is
true for any V that's given by the
gradient of any scalar potential fee
doesn't have to be a special function
fee this first circulation equals to
zero is true for any gradient field
period right that's a vector calculus
identity curl of grad of anything is
zero this second one is a more special
condition this is true for V equals grad
Phee where the laplacian of V equals
zero so for this flux equal to zero I
need fee to be one of these special
laplacian equals zero fees
good okay more questions about this
example
okay I can't restrain myself I'm going
to tell you what happens if I mess
everything up and I say that my
potential function fee is one over Z or
log of Z or some nasty function of Z
that has singularities at the origin so
if I had some function that was singular
at the origin
probably one over Z is not the right one
I think it's one over Z squared or log
of Z or something like that say or log
of Z then what I might have is I might
have a vector field that looks like this
I might have a vector field that has
some rotation which is a problem that
means that my circulation is not equal
to zero right if I integrate over this
contour see the tangent component it
adds up to something that's nonzero this
is what we want if we're going to be in
an airplane we want our airplane wing to
be essentially a stream line with
positive circulation and so it means
that my curl is not equal to zero
everywhere and it means that my vector
field is not a potential degrading of a
potential okay that's a problem but it
turns out that I might still have a
stream function that I can use to
compute the velocity field okay so the
potential part guarantees that I'm
irrotational because grad of a potential
is always going to be ear curl free the
stream function part guarantees that
it's incompressible so the fact that
there exists a stream function is really
what's guaranteeing that I have
incompressibility so the next example
I'm going to show you is kind of a
degenerate potential flow and degenerate
potential flows are actually what we're
interested in from engineering
situations so what we do is we take a
relatively well-behaved vector field
that's curl free and divergence free and
then we give it a singularity at a
couple of points we have putt vortices
or
some kind of singularity and add a few
points and that gives our system a
little bit more physical use like
airplanes so for an airplane the
discontinuity at the tail the sharp
trailing edge is where you get all of
the circulation from because it if you
didn't have some circulation around your
airfoil
you would essentially have an infinite
velocity hat where the flow tried to
turn the corner around the tail of the
airfoil I'll tell you about this later
so let's take this stream function psi
of X and y equals sine of PI X and sine
of PI Y and let's look at this on a
domain which is from zero to two in the
X direction and from zero to one in the
Y direction okay so we're going to look
at this in a little rectangle zero one
two zero one we're going to look at this
the vector field from this stream
function over this domain okay this is d
okay so the first thing we can do is
compute a vector field V okay so V
equals V 1 and V 2 now what it would be
1 and V 2 in terms of my stream function
partial by partial Y and minus partial
psi partial X how many of you have seen
Lagrangian mechanics and Hamiltonian
mechanics some of you okay this is
starting to look a lot like a
Hamiltonian okay so the stream function
level sets of psy sia is basically the
same as a Hamiltonian function okay you
get a vector field from taking this
weird skew-symmetric partial derivatives
and level sets of psy are energy
conserved surfaces okay interesting so
this is equal to partial of this with
respect to Y is PI coast of PI Y so
that's PI sine PI X cos PI Y and PI
minus PI coast PI X sine PI Y okay not
too bad and if we want what we can do is
actually bring this up in MATLAB so this
defines a vector field this defines I
don't remember what the doesn't really
matter but I think it basically defines
a vector field that looks like this so I
have this kind of rotational course and
they're going in equal and opposite
directions okay
so this could not be the gradient of a
potential function because this has curl
nonzero curl but it is divergence free
so I can define it using a stream
function okay and what we're going to do
I don't have time today so I'm not going
to push it we're going to code up this
vector field for example in P plane
right in P plane I could literally type
X dot equals this function of x and y y
dot equals this function of x and y and
I'm going to get a vector field that
looks like this and I can drop particles
in that vector field and I can see where
those particles are advective and
they're going to go in these funny
little closed contours okay so what
we're going to do on Friday's lectures
we're actually going to code up this
it's called the double gyre gyre just
means rotation this is a double gyre
vector field we're going to code up the
vector field that comes out of this
fancy stream function you can verify
that this is in fact rotational this
does not have curl 0 but it isn't
compressible and then what we're going
to do is we're going to start making
this time-dependent so we're going to
make this a function of X Y and time by
putting in a time-dependent frequency F
and what that's going to do is it's
going to slosh the gyres back and forth
so one's going to get bigger while the
other gets smaller and then they're
going to alternate so the other one gets
bigger and this is a model for ocean
mixing so you have big vortices and big
currents and circulations in the ocean
and depending on the seasons and the Sun
load some of them get bigger when others
get smaller and they slosh back and
forth and we're going to integrate
particles through this induced vector
field so we're going to solve the Oh de
for what a particle does and we're going
to get some quantification of what the
mixing and the simple ocean model looks
like so this is a real research problem
you know with collaborators we've
written papers on this this is something
you can actually start using I'll give
you the code and you can like actually
do research on this problem if you're
interested ok that's where this is going
I'm going to hand out the midterm
online after my office hours in one hour
okay thank you
you